sono carlo ho 24 anni e sono qui per
dirvi che da adolescente a causa di
gravi problemi familiari che hanno
colpito la situazione di salute dei miei
genitori ho vissuto in una comunità per
minori
ora potrebbe esserci un po allestita e
davvero io ho sempre fatto fatica a dire
che ho vissuto in comunità perché spesso
la gente non sa esattamente che cosa sia
una comunità e mi ha capita io ci ho
provato a spiegarlo ma tutte le volte
che prova a dire che sono in comunità la
reazione della gente tipo
ho capito hai vissuto in comunità e
sentito è ti volevo chiedere se non è
una domanda troppo invadente non hanno
né no prego prego a me fa molto piacere
raccontare la mia storia va bene grazie
carlo e sinte no ti volevo chiedere ai
vissuti in comunità perché hai ammazzato
qualcuno
no no no no assolutamente
non intendo un carcere minorile intendo
più una comunità per adolescenti capito
ah sì sì sì ho capito grazie mille ema e
quindi se se posso chiederti da quant'è
che non ti droghi no no no no no no
spiego meglio
non intendo neanche una comunità di
recupero intendo più una comunità per
minori hai capito
ah sì sì ho capito grazie carlo dai beni
mi fa molto piacere sì ma è quindi una
comunità per minori mentali non mi drogo
dati scritto a 5 anni va bene
si è difficile è difficile tipo alle
superiori e io purtroppo ho avuto poche
occasioni di di reni e compagni di
classe che ho vissuto in comunità e loro
non sapeva molto bene cosa forse mi
bollavano un po come quello che ha
vissuto in comunità e ho avuto poche
occasioni di fargliela vedere finché un
giorno è successo inaspettato
sono tornato tardi da una gita
scolastica con la mia classe mezzanotte
e mezza ed è venuto a prendermi col
pulmino della comunità la mia educatrice
e abbiamo riaccompagnato a casa perché
era di strada mio compagno fede e
durante il tragitto
emozionato perché stavamo parlando di
comunità siamo sul pulmino chissà fede
cosa starà pensando in questo momento è
infatti il giorno dopo quanto da me e mi
fa
carlo posso farti una domanda
sì sì sì di mimì pure fede
ma quella di ieri
era la tua educatrice
si federa la mia educatrice in comunità
perché
ma quante bona
c'è ora capirete perché io sono qui
stasera e all esigenza di spiegarvi bene
cos'è una comunità ora vivere una
comunità per minori non è facilissimo
perché immaginatevi siamo otto ragazzi
tutti lì perché purtroppo non possiamo
più stare con la nostra famiglia in un
appartamento al posto di genitori
abbiamo quattro educatori siamo in tanti
una delle domande che mi viene fatta più
spesso ma in così tanti come fate la
spesa la spesa la facciamo normalmente
ma una volta a settimana ci vengono
donati prodotti invenduti dei
supermercati vi assicurerà bellissimo ci
arrivavano queste montagne di scatto in
ogni enormi pieni di roba buonissime
ma scadute
cioè si creavano degli ecosistemi a
parte dentro quelle confezioni
diventavano vivi gli alimenti ok non sto
scherzando una volta ci sono arrivati
saltimbocca alla romana erano talmente
scaduti che appena riaperti questi 26
busta prima di aprirvi mortacci tua
certo che a grazie
alla faccia la cosa più semplice che mi
è venuta in mente mi faccio la pasta
aglio olio prendo l'aglio prendo l'olio
e dico non saranno scaduti vero sento
aglio olio mi sa che chi è scoperchiato
e state zitte stipite
sì io col cavolo col cavolo ok che
pulisco le pentole e poi mi prendo la
sgridata dagli educatori
è giusto un'altra domanda che magari
qualcuno di voi si sta facendo come
passare dall avere due genitori ad avere
quattro educatori e
passare da due genitori a quattro
educatori un po
come come le offerte che trovi nei
supermercati 2x4 per intenderci che tu
vai li vedi i prodotti in offerta due
per quattro voi siete contenti e
soddisfatti che ci sono i prodotti in
offerta peccato che quando li compri
scopri perché sono in offerta perché non
li vuole nessuno perché gli educatori in
tutti i ragazzi che ci sono in comunità
si agitano sono se come dei robot sono
sempre lì a starci dietro che dicono fa
il turno bagno pulisci la stanza prendi
vestiti porte di spazzatura ma sono
esagerati ma talmente tanto che una
volta torno anche ritardi da un'altra
gita scolastica a mezzanotte e mezza
entrò in comunità che non ci venivo
praticamente da una settimana e trovo
flavi ma il mio educatore non mi vedeva
da una settimana come ogni bravo papà
che si rispetti mi accoglie con un
caloroso
essere di materia organica dotato di
autonomia intelligenza propria ai
sistemato camera tua
flavia non lo so ma sono appena tornato
ma poi dici sempre le stesse cose sembri
un robot non dire stupidaggini
hai preso i tuoi vestiti che poi anche
sta storia dei vestiti e delle della
camera è esagerato ora non so se i
vostri genitori vi stavano dietro no
tiene in ordine la tua camera ma anche
lì è esagerato flavi una volta lo vedo
uscire da camera mi ha preoccupato
preoccupatissimo è una persona normale
pensa cosa che sarà successo invasione
di sarah degli scarafaggi saltimbocca
alla romana
non lo so e flavio cosa è successo c'è
un problema in camera tua sì questo
l'abbiamo capito tutti ma cosa che è
successo mi raccomando non deve entrare
dentro posto un attimino perché devi
farli ispezione e si possono cimino
entrare perché non devi entrare
nell'area fine che non ho finito entra
[Applauso]
non c'è da ridere imbarazzante
[Musica]
si è rotto questo parlo di cose
ispezione effettuata giorno 27 ottobre
il vino e 14 23 33 e 37 secondi
l'ispezione si è premurata di effettuare
la densità dell'ossigeno nell'aria
deposito i poveri sottili materiale
organico e inorganico sulle superfici
piatte sì quindi risultato
dell'ispezione
la tua camera fa schifo pulisci la
uno stress
però io ho avuto l'opportunità di
cambiare le cose
perché più avanti crescendo io mi sono
laureato in scienze dell'educazione e le
circostanze della vita mi hanno portato
a lavorare per un anno da educatori in
una comunità per minori
e io quello che mi sono sempre sentito
dire è che i ragazzi li capisco perché
loro hanno vissuto le stesse cose che ho
vissuto io quindi io potevo cambiare le
cose è infatti l'ho fatto cavolo se l'ho
fatto
quando entravo per esempio non è che gli
accoglievo subito con fai questo fai
quello più accogliente non lo so ad
esempio attacca volturno la domenica
entravo in modo più morbido tipo ciao
ragazzi allora come state tutto bene e
buona domenica
ciao francesca allora come stai bene ha
appena fatto colazione
luna la prova grande e sentirono poi
sistemiamo il tavolo della colazione che
un po un disastro ma sistemiamo nel
senso sistemiamo al tavolo della
colazione
vai a fumare vai fumare va bene però poi
mi raccomando facciamolo ragazzi
ascoltate ma non timi lavarmi le mani
che sono appena arrivato e
ragazzi cè un disastro in questo bagno
sembra che non l'abbiano pulito da 365
giorni
magari poi pulitelo leonardo non sto
dicendo a quello dei farr to die ma non
litigate ragazzi dai ma non c'è bisogno
ma sono sempre esagerati stiria porca
miseria vabbè allora cosa c'è da fare
alban alba ah no sì ho capito che stai
giocando però lanciare lo stendino e il
mio collega mi sembrano proprio sì lo so
che stai giocando ma dai magari dopo
puliamo la la stanza e vai a fumare ai 7
anni poi mare grande e no ma dai ragazzi
per favore
diamoci una mano sistemiamo anche quella
montagna di
vestiti
quelli sono i vestiti di luca
e da due settimane che gli dico di
prenderli
adesso vado su il picco su per il naso
luca
sono impazzito no ora vi spiego cosa
avete sentito in questi minuti è un
monologo in cui vi ho raccontato un po
in una chiave diversa dal solito le
comunità per minori un argomento
sicuramente delicato un po complicato
perché ho scritto questo monologo ora io
tendo a precisare non sono proprio un
allegrone nella mia vita nel senso che
io tendenzialmente se una persona che
fatica a ridere delle cose a prenderla
alla leggera anche se forse in questo
pezzo non sembra
però a me la comicità aiutato molto a
prendere le cose alla leggera perché
spesso mi sono trovato davanti alla vita
che l'ho sempre vista come una cosa
complessa volte la vita la realtà ti
mettono davanti a situazioni molto
dolorose e per me la comicità è sempre
stata quel canale quella via quella
prospettiva che ti permetteva di entrare
nelle cose in una maniera un po più
leggera
per questa è una ricerca secondo me
perché per riuscire a trovare una via
più leggera volte per affrontare le cose
la realtà bisogna guardarla
e non è facile perché bisogna incontrare
anche le sofferenze e perché ridere
delle cose secondo me
e soprattutto come perché adesso
parliamoci chiaro
per la mia esperienza
ridere quando entro in comunità non fa
ridere sei triste sei perso ti manca a
casa tua
tenevo andare subito
anche se poi si rivelerà un bel posto ma
ai knicks non fa ridere o così come
quando muore un tuo caro parente a me
purtroppo è successo che è mancato mio
padre quando avevo 16 anni e non ha per
niente fatto ridere la cosa ma questo
credo che lo sappiamo tutti il fatto è
che ad esempio al funerale di mio padre
eravamo tutti tristi a me questa cosa
devastato in questo mare di tristezza
non lo so ho iniziato a pensare ai
momenti belli passati kolyma quelli
divertenti quegli stupidi
quando facevo gli scherzi quando
quando i momenti più leggeri e lo
sentivo molto vivo molto più che magari
piangere questa è stata la mia
esperienza che incredibilmente
pensare riderci un po su gli ha permesso
di sentirlo più vivo che mai in quel
momento lì e la cosa interessante che la
comicità in grado di sfidare la morte la
risata in grado di sfidare la morte c'è
ad esempio in comunità tu non ridi
quando entri inizia a ridere quando ad
esempio iniziato a ridere quando quei
ragazzi dell'associazione agevolando che
un'organizzazione di volontariato di cui
io faccio parte
abbiamo iniziato a condividere un po i
momenti in cui magari abbiamo deviato le
regole in comunità o i momenti belli
momenti brutti e li ridevamo ma perché
iridi perché tu ti rendi conto gero
punto che in comunità tu non finisci in
comunità
tu inizi qualcosa di nuovo in comunità
quando vai ti ci sono finito in comunità
e finita la mia vita è vero è finita la
tua vecchia vita mai trovato qualcosa di
nuovo qualcosa di bello e la risata a me
ha permesso ogni tanto di fermarmi dire
davanti magari tutti i problemi
familiari e alle rotture di scatole a
tante cose con la paura la frustrazione
davanti ogni tanto fa ha permesso di
dire senza ascolta la mia
respirare guardare guardare non lo so
quanto è buona la mia educatrice così
per dire c'è però è stato molto utile è
l'ultima cosa che volevo dirvi che per
me è stato molto importante sulla risata
è che come vi ho detto la risata
meritato ad aprire prospettive nuove
sulla mia vita perché la guarda in
un'altra chiave di lettura
e mi ha permesso di vederla meglio la
realtà ed è anche il motivo proprio sono
al ted in cui sono riuscito diciamo a
portarvi dei miei episodi di comunità in
una chiave un po comica e molto sempre
molto utile raccontare agli altri queste
cose perché poi bastano gli sguardi
bastano bastano delle risate per farmi
arrivare dei ritorni dei ritorni che
sono sempre diversi da tutte le persone
che incontro e questo mi ha permesso di
crescere
quindi la vita è un po difficile però
comunque vada
facciamoci una risata su che alla fine i
primi succo di mela ridere forse siamo
anche noi stessi grazie
[Applauso]